- [Crowd] J-E-T-S, Jets, Jets, Jets!
(cheering)
(yelling)
- You've got your perspective.
(exciting music)
I just want to be happy,
don't you wanna be happy?
(upbeat music)
Screenshots of tweets and
Instagram stories work.
So immediately, with this
team, not stretched thin,
however the fuck you guys
like rolling with each other,
'cause it should be from the photo person,
to the top, to you,
like to me, to the intern,
everybody should be able to play.
I don't know if you guys
slack at what you do.
I really want to get into
the culture of creation.
- That's an interesting philosophy
of how you take a nugget
of a story, and yeah.
- Just why.
It's energy, right?
It's momentum.
It's what happened with
the Jets game last night.
- [Crowd] J-E-T-S, Jets, Jets, Jets!
(cheering)
- It just is.
Sports is such a great parallel,
it's even, and then a
couple things happen,
and it's over.
Momentum.
That's how it actually works.
That's how your life actually works.
You know, it's hard to wrap
your head around energy,
so like thus we don't talk about it
or we make it about people
that like live in mountains with crystals.
I get it.
And usually they do go too far.
- You're describing people's writing.
- Right, crystals, I saw that.
You shouldn't have,
they're too overpriced,
but you need them or something, I saw it.
- But it's good to have them.
- Very good.
The level of content I want
to pump out is extraordinary.
It's higher than anybody here thinks.
Theo, are you wearing a Jets hat?
- [Theo] I'm the biggest Jets fan ever,
you didn't know this?
- I know you're not.
- [Theo] What are you talking about man?
- Name the Jets offensive line.
(mumbles)
Get outta here.
(laughing)
I'll tell you why we need it, by the way.
Strictly for our lives.
I'll let these guys help,
this way you can talk.
This way we can get you some time.
- [Man] Alright, cool cool.
Oh man.
- One gives, one takes.
You guys should be able to figure it out.
So what's your story brother?
- So I'm from Dallas and I
run an energy brokerage firm.
We started back in 2015.
Pretty much right now we're
grossing seven figures,
we're pushing onto eight figures.
Pretty much trying to scale them.
- Is the scaling problem
infrastructure or people?
- Probably a little bit of both.
- Makes sense.
- Right.
- So what can I answer?
- As a consumer, energy.
- [Gary] Yes.
- You pay your bills, you
know, nothing special,
nothing sexy.
- I know nothing.
- Oh, okay.
- [Gary] I know nothing about anything.
- Okay.
- [Gary] But I'm a focus group of one.
- Right.
- [Gary] Like most people
do know what the fuck
they're paying for things
and care about stuff.
- Right.
- I hate everything
that's detail oriented.
So my family, like my
dad, my brother, my wife,
my accountant, like everybody
but me knows that shit.
- [Man] Okay.
- Like I don't even know
if I have car insurance.
(laughing)
That was an actual conversation
I had this weekend.
- [Man] No car insurance, wow.
- Tyler, Tyler, Alex!
Was there an email that went
on about my car insurance
this weekend, or did she
take care of it herself.
- [Man] We're good on car insurance.
- But that was a topic
in the last week right?
- [Man] Yeah yeah yeah.
- I'm not joking.
So think about, if I don't know that,
think about what I know about the delta
between what I'm paying for energy
or things of that nature.
- Right, right.
- No idea.
- [Man] I was saying,
possibly is there anything,
a creative idea that
someone could possibly do?
- Oh I see.
Oh I'll give you a good one.
I'll give you a great one.
You need to make Facebook
and Instagram videos
with the title Did You Know?
- [Man] Okay.
- Heres what I would do.
I would run videos say
did you know that you
could go on a free trip
to Orlando with your family?
And then punchline is
if you switch to this energy.
'Cause then it would say in the bottom
on average a family saves $88 a month,
times 12 is $1000,
the average Disney trip
for a family of four is,
you see where I'm going?
- [Man] Yeah, yeah.
- That shit kills.
- [Man] Okay, so more
of a marketing campaign.
- Oh yeah.
- [Man] Gotcha.
- Yeah.
- [Man] I was just thinking of like--
- I know, I know what you're thinking.
That stuff is too fucking
like hitting the lotto
versus like practical fucking,
just like you do sales.
- Right.
- Right?
(knocking)
- Brrr, right?
It works right?
- Right, yeah.
- Guess what else works.
A marketing campaign that tells
people that if they switch
they save this much money.
And with that saved money they can
send their kid to private school.
They can buy a boat.
They can go on a Disney vacation.
They can eat a better
lunch once in a while.
Do you see where I'm going?
- [Man] Yeah.
- Like utilitarian
Like hey dick,
don't be stupid, switch to this.
It's 113 bucks a month.
113 bucks a month times 12, 1400 bucks.
And then find 19 things in
culture that 1400 bucks buys you.
- [Man] Gotcha.
- And then run Instagram
ads against people
that are fans of Supremes and Nikes,
and say do you know you could have
12 more pairs of fly
sneakers if you literally
just swiped up and clicked this button?
- Okay.
Gotcha.
I think we're gonna deploy
immediately some of this stuff
but is there possibly one
way we could get a shout out
to all my guys waiting back at home?
- Yes, 100%.
Nice meeting you.
- Nice meeting you too.
- Take care.
- [Man] There's an entrepreneur
that I like to follow on Twitter
and also he does YouTube video,
his names Gary Vaynerchuck.
He's very precocious, he's funny,
but he also has a lot of
messages for millennials.
His thing with millennials is that
you're not going to be Kim
Kardashian out of the gate.
You're not gonna have a billion followers.
But you gotta try.
- Long time.
- You have great timing, Meg.
We're in a great mood.
- [Meg] Yeah, really?
- We couldn't be in a better--
- The Jets had a full out win last night.
- Oh great.
- We we're both in Detroit last night.
- I know, I saw that on Instagram.
I was like maybe these guys--
- You we're like are they
gonna be at my meeting?
(laughing)
- My meeting.
It's so weird.
I literally think of it as like,
this is supporting my business.
- 100%.
- And literally it's like I
go to work every single day
and then I leave and go home
and I'm like okay!
- Meg, do you know that,
just like war stories,
literally in November and December
of Wine Library,
well into my late 20s,
I used to like be there until
two o'clock in the
morning, packing orders.
- Yeah.
- That's the best.
- I know, I kinda like it.
- Of course you like it.
It's your baby.
I really, really think
the biggest thing that I took out of this,
that I want you to think about,
and obviously I can't speak for AJ's time,
but mines limited,
but I'm happy to get on the
phone with you when I travel.
I like, I really think
you should think about
selling it only direct to
consumer and select accounts.
A la somebody comes in--
- I agree with that.
- I think it will work.
- 'Cause it's nice to get a 600 card hit
from some little store--
- Meg, do you know why people struggle
with direct to consumer
tampons or deodorant
or all these like Birchbox,
why they struggle,
they all raise so much money
that they have to build
a $500 million company
for it all to work.
Got it?
- [Meg] Mm hm.
- That is not your ambition.
- [Meg] Yeah.
- By the way, I actually
think by not having that,
I'm not saying that's not your ambition,
that it's not your,
it's not your ideology.
- [Meg] Yeah.
- Thus allowing you to
potentially, by accident,
get to $500 million by
doing it nice and slow.
Duh duh duh.
You have one KPI.
Couple hundred thousand in
profit to pay for your living.
I think you should build
a community of people
that fucking care about you.
I think you should spend
two hours a day in forums
that talk about fucking paper
and become like an OG of it.
So that they all like buy from you.
You should start a
Facebook group tomorrow.
Around like whatever
you call what you do is
and your way.
- Yeah.
- And have 780 people in that,
talking about cards and design and paper
and DYI and all that.
- [Meg] Yeah.
- Like I'm telling you.
Don't get sucked up.
Do you know why Vayner
Media built the empire
that you were up against earlier?
I know nothing to this day
about the advertising industry,
and you know it.
I didn't pander to it.
- [Meg] That's really, I
literally never thought about it.
And what's so interesting
is that the amount of
sales that I've had today
from whole sale and from consumers
is exactly the same.
- And ones 50 cents on the dollar
and the other is a dollar on the dollar.
- [Meg] Yeah, yeah.
- You know what's a good
example by the way--
- Because, that's what I
keep thinking about too.
- But that's AJ, because
I would be in esports
basketball and golf by now.
- [AJ] I think you're right though.
- No listen, I believe you.
We won't know the alternative,
that's the beauty of the game.
I'll take a latte, Ty,
when you get a chance.
Oh, another stash.
Why is it so cold in my office?
- It's freezing in this place.
- Oh is that true, good.
These Koreans are no joke.
I need a Twitter post of this.
- [Woman] Not defined by.
- Twitter?
- Yup.
Hey guys!
- [Woman] Hey Gary!
- How are you?
- [Woman] That's a fancy candle.
- Which one?
Like what people don't understand
is a lot of people that
made all this money,
they were high risk.
There's like six Instagrams.
- [Man] Yeah.
- And Uber, there's like six of those.
You know?
That's why I'm becoming
outrageously practical.
I think it's practical in your late 20s
to move back in with your parents.
The only reason you're not
is you hate your parents
or you worry about what
other people think.
Otherwise it's fucking,
I wish I was living with my parents now.
I love my parents, it's cozy as shit,
everything my wife asks me
to do my mom would do for me
if she was there.
(laughing)
I love the summer when
we're kinda more together,
that's the shit.
You know?
I think it's practical.
Like I can't think of an
easier way to make 200 bucks
than to garage sale and thrift.
I need you, D Rock, Andy, I need an Andy,
I'll take a Tyler too.
I wanna do something very important here.
A Tyler, a D Rock, and an Andy.
A Sid too.
Yeah, just bring em all in.
I really, just bring
those characters here.
Very quickly,
and this is why I brought you in,
Quora, and work with him, product hunt.
There's gonna be things we
can manipulate distribution
of that video, that within 80 seconds,
the word on the streets being like,
get a (bleep) meeting with Gary Vee,
who cares (bleep) you're
gonna get (bleep).
'Cause everyone's gonna watch it.
- [Man] You have fun last night?
- Ugh, the most fun
I've had in a long time.
It's the only thing I care about.
- [Man] I know.
- [Andy] What's that?
- It's the only thing I care about,
and they've sucked for the last two years.
So it's like three
years of pent up energy.
Andy, I want us to start
posting the daily Vee episode
immediately on Twitter
through the team, not me,
and making a native clip
of the video that's long,
I like the idea of like a
minute 30 to two minutes
of whatever clip.
So not a BSU for it but
a native Twitter thing,
'cause that's working better,
but just raw video from a scene from it.
Something that will tease
people to wanna watch the rest.
- [Man] Do you want to try
to put the full if we can?
- Yes, when we can.
But if it's like 29, you
know, can you go full?
- [Man] No.
- Is there a limit on the full?
- [Man] I wanna say it's 10 minutes.
- Cool, so the answer is when
they're under 10 minutes,
yes, when they're not I
like the idea of making
a minute 30 to two
minutes max, as a teaser.
And have May or whoever else, got it?
- Lisa Hurwich--
- Because also pushing
right when it goes up
helps the YouTube algorithm.
- [Man] Add on a link?
- Yeah I mean I don't need to, yeah.
Exactly, like heres,
and I'll create default copy for the team.
Like heres two minutes,
lets do that, done.
Heres two minutes from today's episode,
click here to watch the full.
Got it?
Starting tomorrow.
Who won the New York Jets
Detroit Lions game last night?
- [Siri] Last night the
Jets beat the Lions.
48 to 17.
- Yeah they did.
That third quarter though.
- [Man] Watch after this though,
why, it showed up last time with,
why does it show the Niners?
- Showing you the next game?
Yeah they did.
Please tell me you saw this
clip on NFL Network today.
Sorry Marcus, for ruining your meeting,
which is obviously very important.
But I can't, oh I guess it's not here.
Oh actually here.
You just have to watch
this as like a sports fan.
Imagine this happened in Nick's context.
Ready?
- [Man] I watched this
game in a sports bar
in New York yesterday.
I'm watching in a sports bar
and this first thing that happens,
the interception, the pick six.
- Do you know what happened?
Threw an interception for a
touchdown, his first pass ever.
- [Man] Are you kidding me,
here we go again, we're goin'--
- Only two other people have done it
in the history of the sport.
- Okay really, I didn't realize.
I figured it would be like a pretty small.
- [Man] Gary Vaynerchuck
- [Gary] How about my Jets, huh?
- [Man] Good.
- [Gary] You should've
taken Isaiah Crowell
instead of Bilal Powell,
but I think Bilals still
gonna have monster.
- You think so?
- [Gary] Man that was fun.
You forget how much fun it is
when you've had two or
three years of not anything.
- I'm in the room with Gary right now.
We're about to film,
I just wanted you to
give him a little context
from the horses mouth.
- Oh this is for.
- We basically feel that
it's working til I fix it,
but at the same time,
it's just a lot and it's
not necessarily the best.
It's not, like we can't get
your Gary Vee Chinese verified
because your Gary is verified
and they say you can't have
multiple people verified.
And, you know.
- So we're challenging them.
- Yeah.
- Cool.
Sam!
- Sam!
- What's up?
- I think that (bleep) is
like flirting with Andy's head
and I just want to remind him
that we don't wanna do that
and we want to do our own thing.
And I'm joking a little bit.
Here's my big thing.
Let me say my big thing.
My big thing is that I had a really weird
epiphany this morning.
I'm like, oh man, like text messaging
is really, really
important for Wine Library.
I guess here's where I'm going.
I'm going a totally
different place I've realized
without realizing, and
now I've realized it.
You know how you said three months?
- Yeah.
- I assume, like every
culture in the world,
you have other homies that can develop
and things of that nature.
If I gave you money, like freelance money,
to put on one of your
buddies, to like team up,
do you have a buddy?
- Yeah, I have plenty
of developer friends.
- I assumed.
So the thought if I'm like hey,
this is so fucking important
actually I should really
be thinking of this
as a 30 day thing, not a,
you know, I love how we
do it and I love you get,
it was funny, I'm like I love the fact
that he'll get all the experience
for himself, for us.
But I'm probably in a place
where if we get in there,
first of all we should
definitely get in there
tell me what I need to do,
but like I'd love to
get you two to team up
and say like okay cool, we can hire,
and by the way, you have friends,
so maybe there's a way, maybe
they want to work at Uber,
like whatever to trade.
It's money, it's something else.
I think I really want this
thing fast and awesome.
And so, by the way, you
could also come back to me,
you've earned so many stripes with me,
you're like yo bro, I
really want this for me
and do it all, 'cause I really
want to taste everything.
Even as bad as I want
it two months earlier,
I probably would say yes
'cause I want to support you.
So can you marinate on all that data?
(upbeat music)
1:37 pm.
The Japanese spike by
the way, did you see it?
I so nailed it.
The spike in interest exploded in Japan.
It was like this.
Hockey stick.
And now, did you graduate from high school
with somebody famous?
I think we gotta cure our code here.
Right now honestly, I want,
honestly if you told me
you guys were sitting there
and setting up in the
best way we've ever seen
with me creating content.
In a world where I want to click a button,
with the flights that I have coming up,
if we go through October,
from now to October,
and actually I click over
50,000 times in email.
I think we're gonna feel really good.
You know, I'd really like to do that.
YouTube what's up?
Thank you so much for watching my videos.
You're gonna get right
to it, but real quick,
September 24th a
ridiculous, ridiculous event
here at Vayner Media.
This is your time to come.
A barter offer.
My K-Swiss 003, which I'm not wearing,
I'm wearing some other K-Swiss' right now,
But, I don't know if
anyone, Andy you wearing em?
Nobody's wearing em.
Alright good.
The K-Swiss, oh bang!
K-Swiss 003 barter party.
50 pairs right, gets you to the party.
50 pairs, click the link.
It's Gary V-E-E/barter or
if this is an ad, swipe up,
or if there's a link, there's a link,
or if this is a YouTube pre-roll,
just like it's Gary
V-E-E/barter for details
on the party, the event, the networking,
the time with me.
On September 24th, New York City.
Be there, get the details
and the action that's
needed to get the details.
See ya.
- [Man] You wanna do the swipe
up while you're doing that?
(upbeat music)